[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, my
name is Martin Omander,
and I welcome you to
"Google Root Access,"
the show featuring
actionable startup advice.
My guest today,
like last episode,
is Nelson Pereira, co-founder
of the startup TOP Docs.
Welcome to the
show, and would you
tell us a bit about
what TOP docs does?
NELSON PEREIRA: Hi, Martin.
Thank you for having me.
TOP Docs is a cross-format and
cross-platform document editor,
allowing people from
different clouds
to collaborate on Microsoft
Office documents, Open
Office, and Google Docs.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So in the last
episode, we talked
about business
challenges and strategy.
Today, let's talk a bit
about the technology.
You are using the APIs of
several cloud providers,
like the Google Drive
API, I understand?
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
Because when we started
to build this product,
one of the main
challenges was, OK, we
need to have a tool to
synchronize all the documents
across the devices and store in
the cloud, backup, and so on.
So instead of creating
our own back-end,
all these features--
it would take
ages to build-- we
looked at Google Drive
and started to
build on top of it.
Because it addresses
a lot of features,
like syncing, backing
up, provisioning,
backup in the cloud.
All the goodies
are there already,
so we don't need
to build anything.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so you can
just use that cloud storage,
all those features
you mentioned?
You don't have to
build them yourself.
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So then there is an
API for Google Drive.
How do you build your
things on top of that API?
I
NELSON PEREIRA: Well, we
started checking the SDK.
It was a great the way
to go to market first,
to use it's on one of
our first interactions.
But then we started
collecting feedback
from users wanting a more
personalized experience
on Drive.
So we read more documentation.
We learned more about what
is underneath the SDK,
and we found the REST API.
And we started to build
our own customized
features for our
users on top of that.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
you actually dug down
into the technical details to
see what goes over the wire,
and then you could use
the REST API, which
gave you-- it was
a little more work,
but gave you
greater flexibility?
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
It's more work.
But by the end of
the day, you have
more power or more flexibility
to customize everything
that you want on top of the
great Drive platform already.
MARTIN OMANDER:
So the SDK should
be used-- when should you use
the SDK versus the REST API.
NELSON PEREIRA: You
should use use the SDK
when you need to
deliver very fast,
and if the features that
Google Drive has built in
is enough for you,
for what you need.
If you want to customize
for a specific segment,
then go for the REST API, and
you'll have more flexibility.
It will take longer, but
by the end of the day,
you'll have a very good
experience with it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So you're saying you customized
the experience for your users.
What kind of features
are you adding
that's not there already?
NELSON PEREIRA: Well,
we listen to our users
because Google Drive is
a very broad product.
It tries to be
everything for everybody.
It has a large audience.
Our approach has a
specific audience segment.
So based on feedback, we
customized the experience
on Drive for that
specific segment.
One of the features
that they most requested
was a very fast search,
because business
have a lot of
documents on cloud.
So we built a search
engine, and local index,
on device which allows
very fast search,
even when you are offline.
The other feature was
having an entire folder
offline full of content.
Because Google Drive,
right now the client
only offers having
offline files one per one.
And if you have a folder
working on a project with 20
or 40 or 100 files, it's a
pain and takes a long time
to make them available offline.
So--
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
NELSON PEREIRA:
That's two examples
of how we customized the API.
MARTIN OMANDER: You and
Google are basically
innovating together here.
Google's providing
the substrate,
the basic functionality,
that would work for anybody.
But then you know your
segment of customers better
and can build on top
of that, and customize
to your customers.
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
Google did all the hard
work, providing the back-end,
the servers, the
syncing, the versioning--
all the good stuff
about having a cloud.
And then we just customizing
the experience on Google Drive
for this specific segment.
So together we team up and
created a better experience
on Drive for these
specific users.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right,
because you know your users
better than anybody else.
NELSON PEREIRA: Exactly.
And it's also a good API
for use for other startups
which may be building different
features from ours on top
of the REST API
from Google Drive.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So finally, Nelson,
there are a lot
of startups out
there using APIs.
Maybe even most are using APIs,
some providers, from others.
And now that you've done a lot
of API integrations, what would
your advice be to
these other startups?
NELSON PEREIRA: Well, if you
need very fast integration
and standard
features, use the SDK.
It's really easy
and fast to build.
You can do it in a day or less.
But if you need to
customize because you
have a specific audience,
you have specific needs
from users-- not a very
general, like Google Drive is
for general public-- to the
REST API, learn about it,
and build their own features,
customized for your audience.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
And you, I understand,
are going mobile first.
What are you
thinking behind that?
NELSON PEREIRA: Yes, we are
building everything mobile
first, because mobile is
the biggest challenge.
If you are able to implement a
feature on a mobile platform,
going back to the
desktop will be easier,
because you have much
more power and flexibility
on a desktop computer,
on the browser.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Great.
Well, thank you very much
for sharing your experiences
with us today, Nelson.
NELSON PEREIRA:
Thank you, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope that
you found something useful there
that you can use
for your startup.
If you have comments
on the show,
file them under the
YouTube comments section.
We love comments, and we
read everything you write.
Finally, if you're a
high-tech entrepreneur,
go to
developers.google.com/startups
to learn how Google
can help you.
That's it for now.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]